The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --
All the things would be
relevant, so here are some
examples from a couple
of lectures ago.
And so here we're thinking about
what happens when we add
an inert gas.
And remember, it's all about
the partial pressure.
So, you always have to ask
yourself did the partial
pressure change, and partial
pressure's going to change if
there's a change in volume.
So, the secret in this problem
is realizing that if inert gas
is added, and the total pressure
is kept constant,
what had to have happened?
Yup, the volume would have had
to increase, and so the system
is put at stress, and it
responds in a way to minimize
the stress.
So it's going to respond in a
way to go from fewer numbers
of molecules to more
molecules.
So, on one side of the equation
reactants there are
three, and on products there
are two, so it's going to
shift toward reactants.
All right.
So today we're going to have
another clicker competition,
and because it is Halloween,
this is the prize for the
recitation that has the
most correct answers.
So, let's see how we do today.
All right.
So we're going to continue
where we left off on
Wednesday, and so these
are your notes --
I've added them to today's
handout and they're also in
the handout from
the last class.
And I want to make a note that
it's a good idea to start this
problem-set early.
You don't know everything you
need to know to do the
problem-set, but you do know a
number of them, so there's
some questions on thermodynamics
and
equilibrium, and Le Chatelier's
principle, you can
do all those problems. So next
week -- today we're going to
talk about bases and buffers,
and then we're going to move
into acid-base titrations
on Monday.
And so, the problem-set looks
like it's not that long, it's
not that many questions, but the
acid-base titrations have
many parts, and each part
is actually quite long.
So it's a very deceptive
problem-set.
So don't be fooled by the total
number of questions.
All right, so we were talking
about acid and water and base
and water and p h, and so we're
going to continue with
base and water right now.
So here we have a base in water,
and so in this case,
the water is acting
as an acid.
It's giving up a hydrogen ion
or proton to the n h 3,
causing it to form its
conjugate, n h 4 plus, ammonia
ion, and also hydroxide ion.
So here we have a base in water,
and when we're talking
about a base in water, we're
going to talk about base
ionization constant, or k b.
So at the end of last class
we talked about the acid
ionization constant, or k a, and
when you're talking about
bases, you're going to
talk about k b's.
So, k b, it's an equilibrium
constant for this reaction of
a base in water, and so it'll be
equal to the products in h
4 plus and hydroxide ion over
the reactant, n h 3.
The water is the solvent here,
and since this is all pretty
dilute, it's mostly pure and its
concentration isn't going
to change, so it's
not included in
that equilibrium constant.
So we have a k b when we're
talking about a base in water.
And we were talking about a base
in water, the equation
should work that you
have hydroxide ions
on one side of it.
So here, the k b is 1 .
8 times 10 to the minus 5 at 25
degrees, so that's a fairly
small number.
And so the small value tells us
that only a little bit of
the n h 3 is going to ionize
when it's in solution.
So only a little bit it's going
to form n h 4 plus and
hydroxide ions.
So that's what that small
number tells us.
So that tells us that it's
going to be a weak base.
So a strong base is something
that's going to react pretty
much completely to go to
hydroxide ion concentration.
A weak base only ionizes
a little bit in water.
And you can tell about whether
something's strong or weak by
its k b value, or if it's
an acid, it's k a
value or p k a value.
So here are some general ways
to write these equations.
We have a base in water and so
the water's going to act as
the acid, base is going to
accept that proton or hydrogen
ion forming a base, h plus,
and hydroxide ion.
So the base is just
written as b.
You could also write the base as
a minus, something a minus
in water going to h a
plus hydroxide ion.
So sometimes you might see that
when you're talking about
a conjugate base
of a weak acid.
So these are two expressions
that you'll see that are
fairly generic that expresses
what happens when you have
bases in water.
Now remember, you know it's a
base in water, you better have
hydroxide ions on the other
side, because a base in water
is going to be forming hydroxide
ions, and acid in
water would be forming
hydronium ions.
So, a strong base, again, almost
completely ionizes to o
h when in water, and here we can
know what's strong or weak
by the k b, so the larger the
k b the stronger the base.
And like there is the p k a,
there's also a term p k b.
P k b is minus log of the k b.
And the larger the p k b,
the weaker the base.
Now you won't see
p k b very much.
It's not used very much,
most things are
converted to a p k a.
So you'll see p k a's quite a
bit, and you will see p k a's
if you take organic chemistry,
if you take biochemistry, if
you take biology, you'll be
hearing a lot about p k a's as
we go along.
Not so much about p k
a's, but p k b's.
And so what I want you to do
when you hear about p k a's,
is remember that you've
learned about it.
Because I have been confronted
by some of my colleagues who
teach in advanced levels, and
they said our students tell us
that you never talked about p
k a's in freshman chemistry.
And I assure them that I did.
So I'll be emphasizing this.
And so I want to make sure that
by the end of this unit
you're really familiar with p k
a's because you'll need them
later on, and I want you to
really impress my colleagues
in later classes, and they'll
say oh, that's a 511-1
student, of course, they
know what a p k a is.
Even my six month old daughter
who's over there, she's like
what, people didn't know
what a p k a is?
You don't want to
get her upset.
OK.
So all of these things are
related with the acids and the
bases, because for every acid it
has a conjugate base, every
base is a conjugate acid.
And so, if you have a stronger
acid, the stronger the acid,
the weaker its conjugate base.
And the stronger the base, the
weaker its conjugate acid.
And this becomes very important
in doing these
problems. So here's a
little table that
emphasizes that fact.
So we talk about
a strong acid.
Most people are familiar with
h c l, hydrochloric acid.
So it's a very strong acid.
And its conjugate base, c l
minus, is not really a base,
it's completely ineffectual
as being a base.
It doesn't really do
anything at all.
A strong acid really drives you
all the way to hydronium
ion concentrations.
It doesn't go back the other
way, it's not really
equilibrium, it's just going
to completion there.
So the conjugate is really,
really weak, basically not a
base at all.
Then we get into this middle
range and here things that are
moderately weak or very weak
acids also have their
conjugates in the weak range.
But if you get to something
that is a very strong base
down here, its conjugate is
going to be also ineffective
as an acid.
So if something is very strong,
its conjugate is
pretty much non-existent in
those properties, but when you
have weak-weak, then you can
start talking about buffers,
which we're going to get into
later in today's class.
OK.
So let's prove that, in fact, it
has to be true that there's
a relationship between the
conjugate acid and its
conjugate base or conjugate base
and its conjugate acid,
that they both can't
be strong.
One has to be -- you have to
be weak-weak, strong or
ineffectual.
All right, so let's look at
the first one up here.
So first let's look at what
is this acting as?
What is n h 3 acting
as, an acid or a
base in this equation?
So it's acting as a base.
And that means water is
acting as an acid.
The water gives up a proton or
hydrogen ion to the n h 3
forming the conjugate
acid of that base.
And then the conjugate base
is the hydroxide ion.
All right, so now let's write
term for k, and so we're
talking about a base in water,
so we're talking about k b.
So k b is going to equal what
-- what do I put up here?
Tell me one thing
to put up there.
Yup.
OK, n h 4 plus, and hydroxide
ion over n h 3.
OK, so we don't have
water in there.
All right, so let's look
at the next reaction.
So what is n h 4
plus acting as?
It's acting as an acid here, so
it's giving up its proton
or hydrogen ion to the water,
which is going to act as a
base and accept that
hydrogen atom.
And when this gives up its
hydrogen ion or proton, it
forms its conjugate base, and
the water is conjugate here,
is an acid, hydronium ion.
So we have our conjugate
acid base pairs here.
So now am I talking about
a k a or a k b?
I'm talking about a k a, so I'm
talking about an acid in
water, and we know this is an
acid in water if we look at
what's happening over here.
So we have an acid in water,
and so we'll put our
concentration of hydronium
ions and n h
3 over n h 4 plus.
So now we have k a's and k b's
written for the conjugates,
the conjugate acid of n
h 3 and n h 3 itself.
So now, we can think about what
happens if we take these
k's and we multiply
them out together.
All right, so we have a
k a and we have a k b.
All right, so we have a k a and
a k b, so if we take our k
a and times our k b, we're going
to just multiply these
out together.
So I'll do this one first, k a
-- just copy from above --
times k b, hydroxide
ion, over n h 3.
And things are going to cancel
out, and so I'm left with
hydronium ion and
hydroxide ion.
What is this, when you
have hydronium ion
times hydroxide ion?
What is that called?
It's another k.
K w.
So we just showed that k
a times k b equals k w.
So we can take the logs of all
our k terms here, and if we
take the log of k a plus the log
of k b equal the log of k
w, or p k a plus p k b equals
p k w equals 14.
So there's this relationship
with a conjugate acid and its
base between its k
a and its k b.
So if one is really big, the
other has to be small or they
can both be sort of
in the middle.
But they're always going to add
up in terms of the p k a
and the p k b to 14.
And the thing about these
problems is if you're given a
k a for an acid, you can
calculate the k b for its
conjugate base, and you'll be
doing that a lot in titration
problems that are coming up.
All right, so there's this
relationship between the
strength of an acid and the
strength of its conjugate
base, and let's just think for
a minute again about this
concept of strong and weak,
because this is really
important for the next unit.
So if we have a strong acid, h
a, in water, it's going to go
pretty much completely over
to hydronium ion and the
conjugate, and this conjugate
is going to be really
ineffective as a conjugate
base, as a base at all.
So it's going to really go
all to that hydronium ion
concentration.
And so, in talking about a
strong base, you don't really
have to worry about an
equilibrium situation.
Just remember it goes pretty
much to completion, and so you
can do complete subtractions
when you're doing this.
And the same is true
for a strong base.
So, for a strong base, any b,
in water, it's going all the
way down, it's driving the
reaction all the way over
here, and you're forming, you
can consider it that however
much strong base you added
is how much hydroxide
ion you have here.
How much strong acid you add is
equal to how much hydronium
ion concentration
you have here.
So however much of a strong
acid or a strong base, you
think they go all the way to
completion, but for a weak
acid we're going to have
equilibrium, and so you'll
have to set up equilibrium
tables to figure out if you
added this much weak base,
how much did it ionize.
So remember that -- people get
worried about the strong acid,
and you just assume it goes
right to completion.
And you can tell again by the
k a's and the k b's what's
going to be strong or not.
And so our definition for strong
acids is that you have
a k a greater than one, strong
base pretty much, the only
problems you use, people are
adding sodium hydroxide or
potassium hydroxide, there are
not a lot of options for
strong bases.
But for strong acids, people
are always worrying about
whether they've identified
those correctly or not.
OK.
So let's look at this relative
strength of acid problem and
do an example here.
So in this equation we have acid
in a base going on one
side, another different acid
on the other side.
So we can look at whether the
reaction is favored toward
this direction, toward the right
or the left, depending
on which acid is stronger.
Will the reaction ride
to the right or left.
So if this acid is stronger,
then it should drive the
reaction this way.
If this is the acid on the other
side, if it's stronger,
then you would expect to drive
the reaction the other way.
So we can take a look at that.
So we can consider the k for the
overall reaction, again,
just products over
reactants here.
And we can also consider the
reaction from just each acid
alone in water.
So we can consider it
separately as well.
So first we can take
a look at one acid.
So if we take a look at this
acid alone in water, it'll
form h 3 o plus and
n h 3 minus.
So when it gives up its hydrogen
ion to the water and
then it forms its conjugate
over here.
So now are we going to look
at a k a or a k b?
K a?
So we're going to have our
products over our reactants,
and the number is quite large,
20, for that k a.
And now we can look at the
other reaction as well.
So we can look at this acid in
water here and form your
hydronium ion concentrations and
your conjugates -- again,
we're looking at that acid in
water, so it's a k a, and we
have our products
over reactants.
Now we have a number of 5 .
6 times 10 to the minus 10.
So, we can consider those two
equations back together, and
this time we're going to be
subtracting the equations from
each other to get our
sum equation.
And because we are subtracting,
we're going to
end up to dividing the
equilibrium constants.
So when we add the equilibrium
constants together, we
multiply things, and if we're
subtracting we divide.
So the k in this case is going
to be equal to the k a of the
first acid over the second acid,
and you can prove this
to yourself, you write up the
k a here, and the k a here,
and then some of your terms, the
hydronium ions cancel, and
you get the k overall
equilibrium constant that we
wrote in the beginning, again
products over reactants.
We know the value for k a for
one acid, we know the value of
k a for the other acid, and we
can divide those to get the k
for the overall reaction.
And then you can tell me what
that k means in terms of which
is the stronger acid of the
two, and which side of the
equation does the reaction lie
to, the right or the left?
All right, let's give
10 more seconds.
Yup, people did pretty
well on this.
So you could have thought
about it in terms of the
overall k or of the
individual k a's.
So, the stronger acid is the
one with the larger number.
And h n o 3 had a number of 20,
so that was pretty big, so
that's a really strong acid.
And because it's a strong acid,
it'll lie to the right,
so it's going to push toward
products -- it's a strong
acid, so it wants to
disassociate a lot, so would
push it that direction.
And you can see that also in
terms of the equilibrium.
Overall equilibrium constant,
if we go back to the slides
for a minute.
So this number overall, k, is
also quite large, very large,
so that means a lot more
products than reactants at
equilibrium.
So again, those are what you can
determine if you're given
a table of k a values, which
on the test you will get a
table of k a values, you can
tell me a lot about different
reactions knowing that
information about k a's.
All right.
So in this unit there are
different types of acid base
problems, and sometimes it feels
for people like there's
an infinite number of different
types of acid base
problems. But, in fact, there
are really only five.
And so one of the things I
strongly recommend in this
unit and working problems is
figuring out which type of
problem it is, and that will
help you a lot in solving it.
So you can either have a weak
acid in water, a weak base in
water, and sometimes you can be
fooled and say oh, it's a
salt and water problem, but
a salt and water problem
actually breaks down to a weak
acid and water problem and a
weak base and water problem.
So it's really not a different
kind of problem, and we'll see
that in a few minutes.
And you can have a strong acid
in water and a strong base in
water, and then you can have my
good friend the buffer type
of problem.
So those are the type of
problems and being able to
recognize them is key to doing
well in this unit.
So let's work a problem in the
first type of a weak acid in
water problem.
All right, so what's
a weak acid?
Well, vitamin C is
a weak acid.
And so sometimes when you're
taking your vitamins you get a
bad taste in your mouth.
And if you did take a vitamin
C tablet here, which is 500
milligrams in this vitamin C
tablet, and dissolved it in
water -- this is not
scientifically measured -- but
dissolved it in water, so you
would say taking your vitamin
with a lot of water, and it was
starting to dissolve and
being pretty unpleasant, then
we could calculate at
equilibrium what kind of p h we
would have in that mixture.
Now, these vitamins, this
Nature's Bounty, they do a
really good job of isolating the
vitamin, so it is pretty
much impossible for
it to dissolve.
So they have a nice coating
around it that's highly
protective, at least at normal
water p h's, so it doesn't
really dissolve.
And one year I thought I would
do the actual experiment, we
could talk about significant
figures, but I could not get
the tablet to dissolve --
I heated it, I stirred it, I did
everything at neutral p h,
at room temperature.
I want to do it at room
temperature, it just didn't
work, even the high temperature
didn't work.
So if you buy Nature's Bounty,
it will not dissolve in the
water that you're taking, so
just for that little bit of
information.
But if you had, say, an inferior
brand of vitamin C
that readily, that didn't have a
nice coating around it, then
you could do this experiment.
So let's take a look at that.
So the first thing that we have
to do is calculate the
molarity of the acid
that we've added.
So here, just have to make sure
that your units are going
to be correct.
So we have grams, we're
converting it with a molecular
weight to moles, and then we
have the number of moles in
the amount of water, and we can
calculate the molarity of
that solution.
And one of the mistakes that
people often make in doing
these problems, they forget to
do all of the conversions that
are necessary, sometimes they
stop at moles, and you're
talking about concentrations
here, so don't forget about
your friend the volume.
All right, so then you can
write and equation, and I
highly recommend that people do
this on the test because it
helps them figure out what type
of problem it is and it
voids people making
silly mistakes.
So if we're talking about an
acid in water, you should make
sure that your equation reflects
an acid in water.
If you have hydroxide ion on the
other side, something is
very wrong that's going on, and
acid and water is going to
be giving hydronium
ion concentrations
and a conjugate base.
So then we can set up an
equilibrium table here.
We calculated the initial
molarity.
And in the beginning there's
nothing over on this side, so
we've just added our
weak acid to water.
And so then the change, there's
going to be some
amount of this that ionizes
minus x, some amount of this
that's formed, and some
amount out of the
conjugate that's formed.
So we have 0.0284 minus
x plus x plus x.
Now we're talking about a weak
acid in water, so what term am
I going to want to use next?
K a.
So I'm going to want to
use k a next -- k a
value is here, 8 .
0 times 10 to minus 5, we have
products over our reactant
here, and we have x squared
over 0.0284 minus x.
Now you can make an assumption
when you're working on these
problems and check it later.
So you can make the assumption
that x is really kind of small
compared to this o.084, and you
can just drop this x out
of the term here.
And then check later and see
if that worked or not.
So that makes the math easier,
and so now we can just solve
for x, and x comes out
to be 0.00151.
The really two significant
figures, but we're going to
carry an extra one for the
moment, so they're just two
figures right here, two
significant figures here.
Now we can check and see if x
was really small, if that
assumption worked right.
So, is 0.0284 minus 0.00151
really the same as 0.0248, and
we let you make the assumption
that it is, we say it's OK if
it's less than 5%
of the value.
So, in this case, it's actually
not, it's 5 .
3, so that violates
our policy.
So it's more than 5%, so then
you have to use the quadratic
equation to solve the problem.
I just want to note that this
term, this percentage, can be
called sometimes percent
ionized or percent
deprotonated, so that you're not
thinking that's some kind
of bizarre term if
you see that.
And if you use the quadratic
equation, you get an answer of
0.00147, again, that's really
two significant figures.
So it's not a whole lot
different, actually, than the
number you got making
the approximation.
So, once you know what x is,
x is the hydronium ion
concentration in this problem,
and so we can plug that in, p
h is minus log of this,
so that's 2 .
83.
And so we had really two
significant figures here, and
so we are going to have two
significant figures after the
decimal point here.
And if you haven't reviewed your
sig fig rules and need
more help if that seems wrong,
then you should definitely
review it before
the next test.
All right, so now we'll continue
with today's lecture
notes, and we're just going to
continue right on and we're
going to talk about weak bases,
and well, we're start
working on our way through,
we're also going to try to get
to buffers today.
So, we've done a problem for
a weak acid in water.
So now let's talk about a weak
base in water, and you can
start us off.
So in this problem we're given a
molarity, so you didn't have
to calculate that, and now you
can help me fill out the table
so we know what to do here.
OK, let's just do
10 more seconds.
Very good.
So you're going to be losing
some of the amount -- some of
the amount of the weak base
you have in, it's going to
ionize, and so then you'll be
forming the conjugate acid
plus x, and you're going to be
forming hydroxide ions plus x.
And so the one with the minus
sign is important, and
sometimes there will be 2's
involved, and that depends on
the stoichiometry
of the reaction.
All right, so we can use that
information now and go on and
look at -- actually you could
leave that clicker question up
for a minute, and we're going
to talk about the k b.
So the k b is going to be equal
to our products, n h 4
plus and our hydroxide ion
concentration over n h 3.
And so now I can fill in the
values that you told me.
So we have, on the top we're
going to have x squared, on
the bottom we're going
to have 0.15 minus x.
And now we can make an
approximation here that x is
going to be small compared to
0.15, and so we can say that's
just going to be equal to x
squared over 0.15, and the k b
value that was given was 1 .
8 times 10 to the minus 5.
So now we can solve for x using
this approximation, and
using this approximation
x comes out to be 0 .
00164, and we can look
at whether that
approximation was OK.
So is this number less than 5%
of 0.15, so we can say 0.00164
over 0.15 times 100, and that
comes out to be 1.1%, so
that's OK, that's
less than 5%.
So that's good, we don't
have to use the
quadratic equation here.
So now, we want to calculate
the p h.
So can I just plug that number
for x into my p h equation?
What is x?
What is x equal to here?
It's equal to two different
things.
What's one of them?
Hydroxide ion concentration.
So what we can do is
calculate a p o h.
So, p o h is minus log of the
hydroxide ion concentration,
or minus log of 0 .
001647, and we really only have
two significant figures
here, and that is going
to come out to 2 .
79.
And so, we would have two
significant figures after the
decimal point, because this
number had two significant
figures in it.
But I'm not done.
I've calculated p o h and
the problem wanted p h.
So how do I go from
p o h to p h?
14 minus, yup.
So 14 .
00 at room temperature
minus 2 .
79 is going to be equal to 11 .
21.
And so that makes sense.
Now in doing these problems
always consider, sometimes
you're rushing and you get done
you say OK, my p h is 2.
But go back and think
about the type of
problem you're doing.
It's a base in water problem.
Would it make sense that the p
h was 2 if it was a base in
water problem?
No.
And so then you realize oh,
I have to do another step.
So that kind of thinking can
save you a lot of points on
the exam, to remember what it is
you're trying to calculate
and go back and make sure that
your answer makes sense.
And sometimes people run into
weird math problems and some
they'll write and say this p h
should be above 7, it's 2, I
don't know what I did wrong,
clearly I did something wrong.
I know that's wrong but I don't
have time to figure out
what I did wrong.
That will get you points.
So just recognizing that if
something makes sense or not
tells us you know what's going
on, and sometimes math issues
can get you into a place that
you can't get out of quickly.
So just thinking about whether
the problem makes
sense is a big step.
All right.
So now, we're going to talk
about salt problems and I'm
going to try to convince you
that salts are actually the
same as the weak acid and weak
bases that we just did.
So a salt is formed
when you mix an
acid and a base together.
So, for example, if you have
h c l and sodium hydroxide,
you're going to get table salt
and a c l and water.
So the p h of a salt in water
is not always neutral.
Sometimes it's neutral,
sometimes it's not neutral.
Well, when would it
not be neutral?
Well, if a salt contained a
conjugate acid of a weak base,
then that conjugate
acid is going to
make it weakly acidic.
Salts that contain things
like iron 3
plus also may be acidic.
So when you're drinking water
and you measure the p h of
that water and it's not neutral,
this could be part of
the reason that there's some
salt in the water, some
different ions in the water.
So a general rule from the
periodic table group one and
group two metals, so lithium,
calcium, sodium, those are all
going to be neutral in solution,
so you can just
remember that.
And if a salt contains a
conjugate base of a weak acid,
then it'll form a
basic solution.
So it's all about whether the
salt derived from a weak acid
or a weak base that's going to
give you a clue as whether
it's an acid or a
basic solution.
If it derived, say, from a
strong acid mixed with a
strong base, then it's
going to give you
a salt that's neutral.
So let's look at
some examples.
So here we have n h 4 c l.
So we can break this down and
think about where a salt like
this would have come from.
So it would have come from n h 4
plus, and it would have come
from c l minus.
So n h 4 plus, let's think about
where this came from.
What is it?
So, we want to ask the question
is n h 4 plus a
conjugate acid of a weak base?
And what is its conjugate
base?
Well, it's conjugate
base is n h 3.
If you lose a hydrogen ion
or proton from n h 4
plus, you get n h 3.
And so you're really asking,
if that's a weak base, then
its conjugate is also
going to be weak.
So you need to know about these
guys to see what would
happen if you have n h
4 plus in solution.
So how do you know about this.
Well, you know about things
being weak or strong based on
their k a's and their k b's.
So, is ammonia a weak base?
It has a k b of 1 .
8 times 10 to the minus 5, so
yeah, that's a small number,
so that's a weak base.
And so it's actually in this
table, so if you have
something that's weak over here,
then its conjugate is
also going to be weak
over there.
These are totally
lined up right.
And so the conjugate over here
is also going to be weak.
And if you weren't really sure
you could always look it up,
so here you have ammonium ion
and it has a k a of 5 .
6 times 10 to the minus 10.
Yup, that's a very small number,
that is a weak acid.
So yes, the conjugate is weak,
the base is weak, and the
conjugate acid of that weak
base is also weak.
So, n h 4 plus does have
acidic properties.
It's not a strong acid, it's a
weak acid, but it will make
things acidic.
So this should be acidic.
What about c l minus?
Do you think it's going to do
anything useful for you?
Where do you think c
l minus came from?
From h c l.
So we could ask again, is
a c l minus a conjugate
base of a weak acid.
The acid is h c l, is
that a weak acid?
No.
So we can look it up if you
didn't remember it, 10 to the
7, definitely not weak -- very,
very, very strong acid,
and if something is strong
acid, its conjugate is
ineffective as a base.
So c l minus is ineffective as
a base so it's going to be
neutral here.
So overall, you have something
that's going to be acidic with
something that's going
to be neutral.
So overall it'll be acidic.
So this particular salt and
water is going to be acidic
because the things that were
mixed together to get it, one
of them included a weak base,
and so that's going to form a
weak conjugate acid, so it'll
be acidic in solution.
All right, so let's look
at another one.
I'm giving you the k a value in
this problem, and knowing
that particular k a value,
tell me what you think is
going to be true about this
particular salt in solution,
whether it'll be acidic,
neutral, or basic.
OK, 10 more seconds.
So, some people were a little
fooled by the information I
gave you, so let's take
a look at this.
So if we go to my presentation
here.
So we can break this up into n
a plus and c h 3 c o minus.
N a plus, is that a conjugate
acid of a weak base?
Is that going to be acidic?
What do we know about things in
group one, a column of the
periodic table.
They're going to be neutral.
Where do you think that this
came from, n a plus, where
might it have come from?
It might have come from n a o h,
that might have been a base
that was added.
So it's not going to do anything
for you -- things in
group one and group two are
going to be neutral.
All right, so we can ask
the question about
a c h 3 c o o minus.
Is it a conjugate base
of a weak acid?
So then we can say is the acid
that it came from a weak acid?
Is its conjugate a weak acid?
Well, how do we know
about that?
Well, we know about that from
the k a value that I gave you.
So is this a weak acid?
Yes.
So is its conjugate going
to be a weak base?
Yes.
So, given that information
we can say yes.
So its conjugate acid
is weak, so then it
would be a weak base.
So if it's a weak base then
it'll be basic in solution,
and we have something that's
neutral plus basic, so overall
you get basic.
All right.
So let's look at a general
example now of this as well.
So here we can talk about
a general rule.
So if you have compound
x y, we can talk about
x plus and y minus.
And for x plus you're going
to be asking about is it a
conjugate acid of a weak base.
For y minus you're going to be
asking is it a conjugate base
of a weak acid.
So for the first part you're
asking about if it's a
conjugate acid, in the second
half you're asking about if
it's a conjugate base.
So if something is a conjugate
acid of a weak base, and
that's yes -- if you know that's
a weak base or you know
that it's a weak acid, then it's
going to be acidic, if
it's not, it'll be neutral.
Same thing is true over here.
You might know about that
something is a weak base, you
might know that its conjugate
is a weak acid, and if you
have a conjugate base of
something that's a weak acid,
then it is a base.
If it's a strong acid it would
be ineffectual, but if it's a
conjugate of a weak acid,
it'll be basic.
No, it's neutral.
So overall, you can have
three possibilities.
Acidic plus neutral is acidic,
basic plus neutral is basic,
and neutral plus neutral
is neutral.
Now some people might come up
with another option here.
What other thing am I leaving
off of this overall?
Acidic plus basic.
That's because I'm never going
to ask you that when
it comes to a salt.
Because pretty much, salts are
formed when you're doing a
titration, and you're going to
be either titrating a strong
acid, a strong base, you're
going to be titrating a weak
acid with a strong base, or
you're going to be titrating a
strong acid with a weak base.
You are never going to titrate
a weak acid with a weak base.
That would yield no interesting
results of any kind.
So you're not going to be
forming salts that are
conjugates of both
those things.
So, if you want to think about
it that way that's fine, or
you could just remember that
that is not what I'm
going to ask you.
These are great little short
answer questions on an exam,
so if you're good at thinking
about this, it'll definitely
give you a couple of points
on one of the exams.
All right, so now and last, just
a couple minutes, I just
want to introduce very
briefly buffers.
So a buffer is something that
maintains the p h of a
solution, so it's going to
buffer that solution.
So if you add a little bit of
strong acid or a little bit of
strong base, it doesn't
matter the p h is
going to stay the same.
So there are two kinds
of buffers.
You have an acid buffer, which
is going to buffer/maintain
the p h on the acidic
side of neutral.
And a basic buffer, which will
maintain the p h on the basic
end of the p h scale.
So let me just give you a brief
example of a buffer and
just get you thinking
about buffers.
So here, in about a buffer
problem you're going to mix an
acid with its conjugate base.
So, you have acetate, and then
probably the acetate salt of
the acetic acid.
So over here, you have the
acetic acid, on this side you
have its conjugate base
usually added in
the form of a salt.
And then you have
an equilibrium.
So, what's going to happen
if you add a strong
acid to this solution?
If you add strong acid, if you
add more h 3 o plus, what
happens if you add more?
What direction will the
reaction shift?
So you'll get the back reaction,
it'll try to
minimize that stress and move
the other way, and it'll use
up some of that acid and
maintain the p h.
Then you can think, so these
amount of acid added is
effectively removed and the
p h stays the same.
What about if you add
a strong base?
Well, that strong base will
react with the acid, it will
remove protons from this acid,
or the hydrogen ion here,
forming this water and
its conjugate.
So you'll make more of these
and the p h will
also stay the same.
So the base is going to be
removed by reacting.
So they're effectively removed
and the p h stays the same.
So in this you have a weak
acid, h a, it'll transfer
protons to o h minus supplied
by the strong base.
The conjugate of that weak acid,
which would be a weak
base, is going to accept protons
from any acid that is
going to be supplied.
So, in this way, you
maintain the p h.
And so I just to emphasize that
in a buffer solution you
have h a, acidic buffer
solution, you have h a, and
you have its conjugate.
And if you only have one or the
other, it's not going to
make a good buffer.
So, I want you to remember that
in buffers you have both
conjugates -- one alone
is not going to work.
And people forget this in the
class, and so you can remember
that for Halloween, your
chemistry professor dressed up
as a buffer to help you remember
that in a buffer
you're going to have both.
You've got to have the conjugate
acid base set,
otherwise it will not buffer.